all right I know that you will know who
I'm talking about right away when I tell
you that a fox news host did something
surprising and that it just made some
sense he told the fox news audience that
they should actually just go and read
the Moller report instead of basing
their opinion on what pundits say
definitely not on what william bars
propaganda letter said and obviously if
you've watched the show before if you've
watched fox news before you would know
that the anchor I'm talking about is
Shepard Smith who has occasionally
pierced the echo chamber of the Fox News
audience take a look
still Nadler says the committee will
have access to some of the special
council's most important files and
that's according to Nadler including
evidence of possible corruption of
justice remember in his 400 plus page
report that everyone in America should
read every one robert muller laid out
ten instances of apparent obstruction of
justice criminal obstruction of justice
potentially by President Trump the
special counselor did not exonerate the
president said if they could have they
would have but they couldn't so they
didn't Muller explained that if he and
his team had confidence that the
President did not commit obstruction
they would have said so he also said
that under Justice Department guidelines
charging the president with a crime was
never an option to him he said the
Constitution requires another process
that's what he said ten instances of
apparent obstruction potentially
criminal did not exonerate Donald Trump
would have said Trump didn't do anything
wrong if they knew Trump didn't do
anything wrong Justice Department
guidelines prevented him from filing
charges other options exist referencing
of course impeachment how bad has the
partisan media industrial complex gotten
that it's newsworthy when someone says
completely uncontroversial but true
things on fox news that happen not to
align with the Republican president's
position and I will go even further by
the way about reading the report I
understand that this is my job and it's
not most people's so reading a four
hundred and fifty page document with
1,500 1,300 however many footnotes I get
that that's not feasible for a lot of
people but there's another
option it's not just you read the 450
pages or you go by the four page bar
propaganda letter there is something
called the molar summary of the report
it's not molars report and it's not bars
letter these are executive summaries of
the report law Fair has these available
which we're linking to if you're
watching on YouTube in the video
description down below the molar report
itself is available as a free audio book
on audible we're linking to that down
below on the YouTube clip do what Fox
News host Shepard Smith says it's crazy
for me to be saying that read the report
listen to the report whatever I've read
almost the entire report I skipped over
some of the parts that were more kind of
like context because if you already know
the context I don't know that there was
that much more for me to learn from that
but I've come away with much knowledge
that I could not have gotten from
William bars letter I certainly would
not have gotten from Donald Trump's
characterization number one Russia's
actions impacted the election they
successfully attacked election systems
period that is in the report number two
there are lots of things that probably
should be criminal in our country that
aren't and what I mean by that is that
there's a lot of indirect involvement
with criminal or potentially criminal
activity that is not a crime including
being a partner to parties committing
crimes even if you benefit from those
crimes even if you had the sense that
they were involved in those crimes if
you're not actively coordinating those
crimes a lot of that activity is not
criminal it probably should be and the
problem we have in this country and I've
said it before and this is just an
example of it on the street crime side
there is way too much criminalization in
our country if you look at the street
crime that gets people into jail and
prison and into the system there is over
criminalization that has taken place
conversely though on the white collar
side on the corporate side on the
political crime side it's not criminal
enough we don't have enough
criminalization and that is a broader
issue that I've been talking about for a
long time here and of course ahead
take away from reading the actual molar
report is that there is substantial
evidence meeting all three of the
requirements for criminal obstruction of
justice by Donald Trump or in other
words on of the 14 possible obstructive
acts 8 of those according to the molar
report meet all three of the
requirements to be criminally
obstructive acts read the report okay
start the impeachment inquiry further
publicize the contents it's time I don't
know what anybody's waiting for if you
love learning new things you probably
want to check this out the David Pakman
show today is sponsored by Skillshare
and we're giving you two entire months
of free access to Skillshare when you
click the link underneath this video
Skillshare is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video